الحوثيون يوصلون استهداف البوارج
الامريكيه والبنتاغون يجهز خطه للرد رئيس
الفصائل يؤكد استعداد قواتهم للمرحله
الثالثه من الحرب الجيش العبري يعد خطه
لتقسيم القطاع هل ينجح وواشنطن توجه رساله
مشفره لتل ابيب والاقتصاد العبري يحتضر
فصائل القطاع تقدم مقترحا لانهاء الحرب هل
تقبل به تلابيب ملثم القطاع يظهر مجددا ما
هي الحصيله سلاح روسي يجعل الصواريخ
الغربيه في مهب الريح فيما كندا والنرويج
تحضران الامدادات العسكريه لكييف مضاعفات
ضخمه في ذخيره الجيش الروسي والغرب يغير
موقفه نتائج الحرب كلما طال امد حرب
القطاع ظهرت مؤشرات جديده تؤكد ان نهايه
الحرب ليست قريبه ونحث الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن رئيس الحكومه العبريه نتنياهو على
الانتقال الى عمليه اكثر دقه في القطاع
تتركز ضد قاده الفصائل واوردت صحيفه ول
ستريت جورنال ان تلابي بدات استعدادات
لقتال طويل الامد حيث قامت باعاده توزيع
القوات للاستمرار في قتال اقل حده على
المدى الطويل ليخرج رئيس المكتب السياسي
للفصائل اسماعيل هنيه ويؤكد ان تلابي بدات
الترويج للانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه من
حربها على القطاع التي ستسقط فيها مره
اخرى امام مقاتل من جانبه كان وزير الدفاع
العبري قد وقف في القطاع وكشف عن الخطه
العسكريه المقبله في الحرب ضمن تصريحات
كان الهدف منها بالاساس نفي وقف العمليات
لكنها افصحت عن تفاصيل اخرى بينما كشف
تقرير من ول ستريت جورنال عن الانقسام
الداخلي في تلبيب حول كيفيه انهاء هذه
الحرب ها هو المصدر يتحدث القول بان
اسرائيل بدات بالفعل تتجهز للمرحله
الثالثه من الحرب وان لم تعلن عن ذلك وعلى
الاغلب لن تعلن عن ذلك هذا وقال قال موقع
اكسيوس الامريكي نقلا عن مسؤول عبري اكد
ان الفصائل قدمت مقترحا في المفاوضات مع
الجانب العبري من خلال وسطاء قطريين
ومصريين من شانه ان ينهي الحرب واشار
الموقع الى انه من شان الاقتراح ايضا
انهاء الحرب بعد تنفيذ المرحله الاخيره من
الاتفاق التي ستشمل اطلاق سراح الجنود
المحتجزين كرهائن في القطاع بحسب المسؤول
فيما اكد الجنرال في الجيش العبري اسحاق
بريك انه مع مرور الوقت ت تعد تل ابيب
اكثر عن تحقيق اهداف الحرب وهي القضاء على
الفصائل واطلاق سراح المختطفين وتغوص اكثر
فاكثر في وحل القطاع وفق صحيفه معاريف
ونقلت هيئه البث العبريه ان الجيش العبري
اعد خطه لتقسيم القطاع الى محافظات
ومحافظات فرعيه تسيطر كل عشيره او عائله
كبيره على احداها مشيره الى انه سيجري عرض
الخطه على مجلس الوزراء الامني للمصادقه
عليها لنات يكم بالمص وذكرت الهيئه ان
القطاع سيقسم الى محافظات ومحافظات فرعيه
تسيطر كل عشيره او عائله كبيره على احداها
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه ليظهر ملثم
الفصائل ابو عبيده ويعلن الحصيله بتدمير
71 اليه عسكريه كليا او جزئيا وتحييد 16
جنديا مع اصابه العشرات ضمن 42 مهمه
عسكريه للفصائل خلال الايام الماضيه
اقتصاديا ذكر صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
تداعيات هجوم الفصائل على الاقتصاد العبري
كانت قويه وان بعض الاقتصاديين يتوقعون
صدمه شبيهه بالاضرار التي لحقت به جراء
جائحه فيروس كورونا في البحر الاحمر بعد
ان كانت مصادر عسكريه يمنيه افادت باطلاق
الحوثيين صاروخين بالستيين استهدف بارجه
امريكيه قرب جزيره حنيش جنوبيه البحر
الاحمر هناك قالت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه في تقرير نشرته على موقعها
الرسمي ان البنتاجون يضغط على اداره بايدن
للتحرك ضد الحوثيين في اليمن مشيره الى ان
البنتاجون عرض خططا لمهاجمه مصانع
ومستودعات الاسلحه والذخيره العسكريه بما
في ذلك الزوارق القتاليه بينما كانت
اعتبرت صحيفه ارتس العبريه ان تقليص
الولايات المتحده لوجودها البحري في
المنطقه رساله غير ايجابيه لتل ابيب وفي
تقرير لها اشارت الصحيفه الى وجود توترات
بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ونتنياهو
حول قضايا متعلقه بالحرب انها علاقه
الاخير بالسلطه الفلسطينيه في لبنان وبعد
ان اكدت الفصائل اغتيال نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لها صالح العاروري واثنين من
مساعديه واصابه عده اشخاص اخرين في بيروت
ادان رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه
نجيب مقات الاغتيال قائلا انها محاوله لجر
لبنان الى شبح حرب وتوسيع دائره الحربي
بالمنطقه اسلحه موسكو الفضائيه سلاح اخر
تعده روسيا لمواجهه اسلحه الغرب هنا قال
الضابط الاوكراني المتقاعد الجس تاركوف ان
روسيا تنشئ مجموعه اقمار صناعيه قويه فوق
اوكرانيا ستسمح لها باعتراض جميع الصواريخ
الغربيه التي تستخدمها القوات الاوكرانيه
واعلنت شركه سبوت نكس الروسيه الخاصه انها
تمكنت من تطوير وتصنيع اكثر من 12 قمرا
صناعيا خلال عام
2023 هذا وافادت وزاره فاع الروسيه في
تقريرها السنوي المنشور بنهايه عام
2023 بان الصناعات الحربيه الروسيه تمكنت
من مضاعفه انتاج الذخيره للجيش بمقدار 17
مره ونصف منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ها نحن نتصفح
[موسيقى]
المصدر بالمقابل اجر الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي محادثه هاتفيه مع رئيس
وزراء كندا جاستن ترودو وشكره على تزويد
كيف بقذائف اضافيه ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي
نا سمز فيما سمحت الحكومه النرويجيه
للشركات المحليه ببيع الاسلحه والمنتجات
الدفاعيه مباشره الى اوكرانيا وفقا لبيان
على الموقع الالكتروني لمجلس الوزراء في
البلاد لتخرج وزيره الخارجيه النمساويه
السابقه كارين كنيس وتصرح ان الغرب غير
موقفه ولم يعد يامل في انتصار اوكرانيا
مضيفه انه قبل عام بالضبط زعموا في الغرب
بان الجيش الروسي شرف على الانهيار وان
بعض التغييرات ستحدث من جهته صرح السفير
الامريكي السابق لدى النيتو ايفو دال ان
اوكرانيا تخاطر بخساره الصراع مع روسيا
ومن المتوقع ان تحصل في النصف الاول من
عام
2024 حسب تعبيره ووفقا لدالد فان اوروبا
لا تملك الاحتياطات ول القدره الانتاجيه
اللازمه لتعويض نقص الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
على الارض الاوكراني اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
اعتراض 72 صاروخا من اصل 99 اطلقتها روسيا
والقصف يتسبب بانقطاع الكهرباء عن ربع
مليون شخص بكيف ليعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
البلاد تواجه تهديدا صاروخيا روسيا جديدا
مشيرا الى رفع حاله التاهب الجوي ها هو
المصدر يتحدث اضاف الجيش الاوكراني ان
البلاد تواجه تهديدا صاروخيا روسيا جديدا
مشيره الى رفع حاله التاهب الجوي فيما
اعلنت وزاره فاع الروسي ان الطيران
العملياتي التكتيكي والمسيرات التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه استهدفت
122 وحده مدفعيه تابعه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في
137 منطقه من جهته اعلن المركز الصحفي
لمجموعه قوات المركز التابعه للجيش الروسي
ان قذيفه قنابل روسيه اغرت على 22 معقلا
ومراكز قياده للجيش الاوكراني على محور
كراسني
ليمان
[موسيقى]
ا